Your main job is making people laugh and you're fucking side hustle was making
keep making people think that's,
that's an amazing style.
So over,
it's overwhelming though sometimes.
So sometimes I,
I do so many of them and I do some of them on subjects where I'm not even well
read.
I don't,
I don't exactly know if this guest is being honest or if they're,
you know,
budget.
But that's how you feel like that's how you cannot,
you fall into shit.
You don't,
you don't like,
you don't,
you don't wake up and know.
Yeah,
you're wicked.
Wake up curious and you could search and you're honest.
You have an honest and integrity with your audience when you say,
I was wrong about this or I've learned to picked up more of this.
I think that's what it's really about.
You know what I mean?
I don't think it's about being right or knowing all the time.
You,
you,
your forum is very dope because it's conversational and not contrived.
It really is me having the ability to ask.
We were talking,
you know,
Google research have these notes.
I don't know if you know what?
No,
of course you don't take a record.
Sure.
An amazing comic when an amazing [inaudible] we know about the Zapruder film.
They exactly,
yeah.
Gregory brought it to Geraldo Rivera.
I knew this man his last three years of life.
Um,
first of all,
first meeting him,
he cursed me.
And tio is though we'd stolen the tires off his car.
Right?
Why would he say,
well,
me and t I just kind of got on like too Hokey wrappers that kind of saw them.
You know,
it,
it's,
you know,
we're,
we've embraced the fact that our community looks at us as leaders,
right?
We're not trying to be Dr Keener Macklin,
but we're businessmen were rappers.
We have accountability and responsibility in our community.
So we accept some of what comes with that and we are willing to do things.
So in considering protesting,
considering,
you know,
talking to politicians on the behalf,
tweet and you have to consult with elders.
So we get on the phone with him like,
you know,
so what do we do?
Like kids are getting shot.
We have,
what should we be engaged or should we wait?
Should we march,
March,
nick,
Nigga,
what the fuck you go march.
We be March 15 years ago.
You know,
they don't open that street up.
Let you mark tell you clothe itself and then shoot your ass if you,
you're
just like,
oh shit.
I never actually,
I never thought of that.
And this is more serious than we're showing up and were angry.
This is confronting government.
And once government has Shane,
you do something a few times you have to practice guerrilla warfare or you're
just doing what the British did that lost them.
America,
you're stepping up in a formation,
shooting your shot,
falling back,
stepping up for,
you're just playing a fucking game where they're dancing versus doing things
that really disrupt the system and things that really progress the move.
And I was like,
Oh shit.
You know,
this is radically,
this guys is more than just a funny man and he's more just stay.
He's really sacrificing lady that shit down.
So yeah,
we got cursed out by Dick Gregory.
Tip Hung Up.
Why you didn't call me back later light man,
you know,
like,
Hey,
my phone messed up tall,
you know,
talk cool.
It's my phone hung up dog.
I don't know how say,
Nigga you Haga he say,
well,
what did he say though?